next comes the best song award and right
here we must thank the American
Federation of musicians and its
president James C Petrillo whose
cooperation makes possible a
presentation of an original musical
score with live musicians and now ladies
and gentlemen it's a thrill for me to
present a personality who for 50 years
has represented an eternal springtime
Maurice Chevalier right here
thank you very much for the nice way you
have been talking about me I'm only
sorry that I cannot I didn't think of
taking your white path and my tears you
know so I'm a bit ashamed and I'm sorry
no but you you you look very nice you
yeah I don't know you're very very chic
and very young well do you know how I've
been able to retain my youth I stayed
out of France until last year but but
you've made a you better picture in
France no I you try to the best you
could you you try to get the Brigitte
Bardot for you leading lady yes I tried
to get her but she's made so many French
films she was home with a cold Greece it
was so wonderful to you to come all the
way from Paris just to join us here
stage is yours thank you I am very happy
because I have been asked to come here
and give the award for the best song of
the year and you know ladies and
gentlemen songs have been very important
in my life
songs have meant a lot and it's
extraordinary because I started to sing
as a pro when I was 11 years old so you
you can see yourself you know and all
this the singers were well kind of
specializing in salt they create a lot
of songs during their career but only
very few of those songs I remember you
see I don't know whether some of they
are good or not but they remember just
two or three four instances in Paris
they remember Valentina
and then to people
and they are Cupertino thought you
should hear me
am I the guy
you know I'd like to have a little son
of the me by ah
simple meter with Charlie told someone
good love me Louie
the right soldier in the right place
with the right girl and Cucamonga can
become Paris in the spring
now you've known a new verb or the
nominated song the winner is all the way
ladies and gentlemen ever so many people
make such an honor possible I'm sure
they'll understand if I think the really
important man tonight is Jimmy Van used
in the Yul Brynner of ask